le'veon bell departed the pittsburgh
steelers for the new york jets he's had
a press conference he's had a couple of
other interviews but he had an extensive
extensive sit-down with jenny ventus of
sports illustrated and there was a lot
of stuff there we touched on some of it
yesterday and one thing that i noticed
after the program i wrote about it at
pft
uh the the
the comments from le'veon bell about the
steelers organization he said pittsburgh
is a great organization they've got a
great owner great head coach they kind
of treat you like they don't treat you
like you're human what i mean by that is
like yeah i'm an nfl athlete but i'm
still a human being i still play video
games i still make music they don't want
you to allow you to be yourself they
want you if you're a steeler you're
literally playing football 24 7. you're
not supposed to be playing video games
and making music playing basketball
you're not supposed to be doing that
you're supposed to be working out my
reaction to that was
every team is that way right is there
any team out there that really treats
the players like human beings
that they want that and i think they get
desensitized to the humanity of the
players because you're constantly hiring
and firing guys right nine over roster
right you've got 90 on your entire
roster for the offseason it cuts down to
53 and then you're constantly churning
it guys go they come back and then you
know the the team is always going to be
there yeah the team's been there in many
cases for you know 100 years for a
couple of these teams the players come
and go all the time and i just think
that it is the exception the rare
exception that there really is a sense
within an organization that you
understand that these are human beings
because if you get that way your heart's
going to get ripped out every time you
have to cut somebody yeah exactly right
you can't get too emotionally attached
you do your best i guess the big thing
too here listen i love le'veon bell he's
like one of my favorite players i think
he's a little bit you know bitter or
personal with some of this stuff too
we've never really heard this from
anybody in pittsburgh history nobody i
mean this is a stand-up organization you
want to go to guys i played with in
college casey hampton you know our man
ryan clark on espn they always have
positive things to say about playing in
pittsburgh it's one of the top notch
organizations in football i think the
big thing is pittsburgh the new york
giants the new england patriots the
green bay packers i want to say maybe
some of the original teams in the nfl
it is maybe a little bit more of a
business and a professional atmosphere
than maybe some of the other teams yeah
pittsburgh's in there when you walk in
the lobby there's there's six super bowl
trophies every day they're not in there
to you know collect more you know
playoff banners they want to win super
bowls and that's the business they're in
and that's just the brutal you know
facts of the situation when you're an
nfl football player especially playing
for an organization like that they
respect you but they expect you to be a
professional we don't hear about the
patriots playing fortnight or making rap
videos i'm sorry and it works really
well so i mean rob gronkowski does
whatever he wants to do well he does
okay but he never lets it distract into
football two off seasons ago was the
first time ever we were like whoa he was
kind of remember he was at the
motorcross thing and he was talking
about i'll get there and i want to get
there i mean that was like the the most
pushed back he skipped the off season
program last year tom brady was hardly
there and they still won the super bowl
yeah well okay they have a little
different circumstances as far as tom
brady has he's in a little different
class like when you're about to go into
year 18 or 19 but i'm just saying still
they treat tom they tom we always talk
about tom's getting lack of love or
respect from new england because it's a
business and it's about winning football
games right now yeah does he get to cut
a little slack there because he's won
six super bowl rings definitely gronk
the same way but still it's an extremely
professional environment and yeah it's
not always gonna be you know oh hey
what's your next career venture and you
know what are you thinking about in
other aspects of life it just it just
doesn't go on a lot in the nfl here's my
assessment i think there is an
inflexibility in pittsburgh that is no
longer practical because the world has
changed around steelers because i think
the core of the problem between the
steelers and le'veon bell was this
structure
right because if you're only going to
guarantee the first year of a long-term
deal yeah and you have a guy who's under
the franchise tag where the first year
is always guaranteed why the hell is he
signing a long-term deal if you're not
giving him any guarantees beyond the
first year it's ludicrous it's asinine
so just be like the patriots and don't
use the franchise tag see the steelers
decided to embark on this path of using
the franchise tag but then they didn't
want to structure a long-term deal the
way everybody else does who has a player
under the franchise tag that they want
to sign to a long-term contract because
it's a given what you do is you take
what the guy's going to make the first
year under the tag you take what he
would make the second year you lump it
together you fully guarantee it and
that's what you do that's the formula
for signing a guy to a long-term
contract whose franchise tag but sales
no we're not doing it that way well then
the guy's not going to sign a long-term
contract and then he's going to make
comments like that because ultimately
that's when you're making him feel like
he's not human because you're going well
you're not really respecting the rest of
my life you're just respecting me that
one year by giving me a little bit
guarantees there i think that's what it
all comes back to i that's where i was
going to get to eventually thank you for
buttoning it all up there for me but
you're exactly right i think it comes
back at the end of the day to that lack
of respect as far as the contracts are
concerned and a guy like le'veon bell
felt disrespected i'm touching the ball
more than anybody in football on a
yearly basis and getting my body beat
the hell up and i just want a little
long-term security for myself and my
family and that's probably where he
feels like he wasn't treated like a
human and think about this i mean this
happens in in any line of work where you
have a set of rules that you just insist
on adhering to
why well it's just because that's the
way we've always done it well that's not
good enough yeah right there's a certain
point where the way you've always done
things needs to change because the world
has changed and everybody else in your
industry has changed and just because
you've got six super bowl trophies and
just because you're the steelers and
it's an iconic franchise with an iconic
uniform and a fan base that will support
you no matter what there's a point where
you have to say
you know what
maybe the time has come
for us to change but there's a
stubbornness there you know with the
giants i said earlier this week i'm
gonna get in trouble again for this but
there's a little it's just a little bit
of arrogance from the organization
steelers there's a lot of stubbornness
yeah and that is if they had just
structured the deal the way they should
have in 2017 he'd be entering year three
of his long-term contract and everything
would be fine and no any he wouldn't be
out there trashing his quarterback ben
rothschild no no he he would not you're
right i think it all comes back to that
and you know to what you're saying too
you talk about yeah the giants and and
the pittsburgh steelers you know it's
okay to have old school values right we
want
i understand that but let's not be like
all we have such old school values that
we never change i mean again i'm going
to use the example again because they
are the standard in professional sports
the new england patriots they get a lot
of old school values but belichick is
always looking for new ways to do a
contract or new ways to formulate my
team or new ways to train or hyperbaric
chambers for my coach to sleep yeah they
didn't do that in 1960 when he was in
the naval academy or anything like that
but he said you know what this makes
sense i have a brain i can think and
this will make my team better and i'll
also keep the old school values of be
here on time work hard be accountable
don't make excuses and all those things
and i think sometimes that's where teams
kind of lose their way there this is why
we did it back in 1944. okay great it's
not that time anymore change move on the
world's change that's a great point he
always is looking for new ideas and i
see what the dolphins are doing trying
to unload guys they don't want without
cutting them and paying some of their
salary so they can get a trade and get a
draft pick you'll wonder did brian
flores advocate that because all of a
sudden the dolphins are doing this as
brian flores is the new head coach yeah
did he advocate that and bill said no
and now he has a chance to do it and
he's doing it he's showing him how it
can work and if it works bill belichick
will not hesitate to do it he will do it
exactly right no and i think i think
what probably brian flores is maybe
brought to the conversation there in
miami we saw a lot of years right and
let's not forget this when the patriots
would trade out of the first round or
constantly trade down and acquire picks
right and more picks and more picks to
them when the year was right oh they'd
make a move and get dante hightower and
chandler jones in the first round or you
know even last year with sony michelle
and isaiah win but so i think that's
ultimately probably what brian flores
has kind of infused into miami like hey
it's we're rebuilding let's get some
assets let's get the draft picks to make
moves and shuffle things around and
trust that our evaluations uh will be on
point and that's how we can steal a few
extra players to build this roster even
better than than we've ever had it back
to the steelers le'veon bell has echoed
some of the concerns that we heard from
antonio brown i mean antonio brown went
scorched earth in his effort to get out
of pittsburgh attacking ben
roethlisberger relentlessly le'veon bell
said that that ben is a great
quarterback the organization wants to
win mike tomlin wants to win ben wants
to win but ben wants to win his way and
that's tough to play with ben won a
super bowl but he won it when he was
younger now he's at this stage where he
tries to control everything and the team
let him get there and that let him get
there that was the same thing happened
with antonio brown he wants to show up
whenever he wants and the team let him
get there he wants to have a different
standard for himself the team let him
get there there's a lot of that the team
let him get there going on in pittsburgh
and i hope they've learned from that
that moving forward you can't let your
star players dictate their own terms the
rules have to apply across the board
just like they do in new england they
apply to everybody exactly if you're
late you get sent home if you're bad
you're getting called out even if you're
tom brady we're not going to tiptoe
around anybody right and for whatever
reason
ben roethlisberger and antonio brown got
a lot more leeway than everyone else
we've seen them abuse that leeway in
very different ways but those were two
big ingredients in this toxic stew that
that eventually doomed the 2018 season
and hovers over 29. yeah no i no doubt
and you know and and i know i'm going to
say this too with big ben big ben's
always been a handful he was a handful
under bill cower too so this was not
just a mike tom one thing so you know if
we're going to talk about this creation
yeah bill cower had to deal with some of
the diva aspects of of of the first
moment the 2004
afc championship game rookie season they
lost to this to the patriots yes and
after the game rothersburger said i
played with three broken toes and bill
cower said he doesn't have any broken
toes that was the first moment exactly
right so that was our first inkling of
oh this guy is a little theatrical at
times again big man is awesome he is a
phenomenal football player i do not
agree with the way he acts and maybe
leads at times but do i think he's in it
for any alter ulterior motives other
than winning football
and trying to make the steelers better
football team no i think he is all about
that he's a great competitor he's a
great talent you know even when i hear
about not throwing the ball to antonio
brown you know what i think happened
this year i think this was just the
first year in antonio brown's life in
big ben's life where when things were
equal right the coverage was equal on
antonio brown and juju smith schuster i
think big ben found more of a comfort
level throwing to juju smith schuster
and that probably pissed antonio brown
off as well but there are guys sticking
up like we haven't even talked about
marquis pouncey and how he kind of stuck
up for big ben too i thought he's on the
team but that's a nice strong comment i
appreciate it you always want to say
good things about a guy whose hands are
going to end up in this button
i was trying to be a little more subtle
than that but yeah i'll i'll do it no
here's one thing we got to take a break
but we spent a lot of time talking about
the under achievement of the green bay
packers over the last eight years think
about this 2004 ben roethlisberger
rookie season
they were 15-1 right afc championship
game 2005 they win the super bowl 2006
disappointment coward leaves in comes
mike tomlin they won a super bowl his
second season right
they've been to a super bowl into
another one lost to green bay but it's
but but
why is there not the same
like and i'm asking us yeah we've been
all over the packers for not living up
to their potential and maybe it's
because the steelers have to deal with
the patriots in their own conference
maybe that's why maybe if the patriots
in the nfc we'd cut the packers some
slack but why haven't the steelers done
more with ben roethlisberger with
le'veon bell with antonio brown
somebody's to blame there yeah well the
other thing too we can't forget they
couldn't get on the field in the same
time i mean there was the three b's and
we had years where it was only two bees
because le'veon was hurt or big ben
would get banged up or antonio so they
never even got to play together all the
time either i think that's uh something
you gotta kind of go back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports